et le Golden Globe est décerné
àer dowy j Robert dowy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
junior
oui
oui j'ai pris des BTA blocants donc ça
va être vraiment
facile une histoire énorme sur le
dilemme éthique des armes nucléaires qui
fait un milliard au boxofice est-ce que
ça col non mais comme Universal a tout
misé sur Christopher Nolan pour dirigé
Kylian Murphy avec Emma Thomas à la
production avec Émilie et Florence et
toute l'équipe la distribution et bien
ça a permis de faire un de chedov
voilà c'est pas tellement difficile à
comprendre il y a pas mal de gens qui
sont venus me voir et depuis l'été pour
dire que j'étais euh méconnaissable dans
ma subtilité en tant que le Straus alors
pour les conommé
ne faisons pas comme si c'était un
compliment c'est la première fois c'est
un peu comme meilleure
amélioration alors pour rasken et dlap
qui me conseille dans ma carrière ils
m'ont dit qu'il fallait que je relance
ma carrière c'est tellement amusant de
montrer que les agents ont raison et
pour parler de ce qui m'a motivé et là
Suzanne Daun qui est mon infirmière en
chef
a permis de me sortir de ma zone de
confort qu'elle a transformé ça en air
parce que moi j'ai besoin de me sentir
en sécurité et enfin les journalistes
des Golden Glob merci d'avoir changé un
petit peu votre fusil d'épauulle et
d'avoir changé de nom
salut